ces retrouvailles aujourd'hui si
familière semblait impossible il ya un
an
étaient déployées en afghanistan en 2010
hakim aziz sy était son interprète
l'été dernier lorsque les tensions se
sont intensifiées twins avec hakim
allait devenir une cible pour les
talibans il a remué ciel et terre pour
s'assurer qu'il puisse avoir son visa et
fuir kaboul acquis muscroft
hakim se cacher chez un nom raconte
l'ancien militaire et il attendait
d'abord une occasion de se rendre à
l'aéroport mais tout allait si vite que
jour je lui dit vas-y
et on refonde abbas frappe à la porte
espérons que ça fonctionne
quand nous sommes arrivés des milliers
de personnes se ruaient sur les
barrières nous n'avons pas été capables
de franchir la porte explique akim après
trois tentatives l'interpréter sa
conjointe ont finalement pu embarquer
dans le dernier vol canadien quitté
kaboul mais tous n'ont pas eu cette
chance
nous avons un autre interprète avec qui
nous sommes en contact mais il est dans
un camp de réfugiés à islamabad avec ses
cinq enfants depuis un an déplore tyson
nous n'aurions pas pu mener notre
mission en afghanistan sans ces gens ils
ont mis leur vie en danger pour nous et
maintenant nous les laissons derrière je
ne comprends pas pour moi on ne laisse
jamais un frère derrière le canada s'est
engagé à accueillir quarante mille
afghans jusqu'à maintenant dix-sept
mille sont arrivés dix mille dans le
cadre d'un programme humanitaire et plus
de 7000 dans un programme réservé aux
afghans qui ont aidé le canada on
n'était pas rigoureux dans nos
politiques régionales pour prévenir le
retour des talibans et tout le monde
tout le monde tous les pays qui ont
participé à cette mission devrait
assumer
leur part de responsabilité
pour l'ancien ambassadeur canadien en
afghanistan le canada à notre devoir
d'en faire plus on devrait viser
accueillir au canada au moins cent mille
afghans j'ai clairement un échec et
l'opposition conservatrice déplore que
le gouvernement se borne à fixer une
limite au nombre d'afghans que le canada
doit accueillir c'était des injustes qui
a été lancée en l'air d'un chiffre qui
s'est élancé pour faire de la politique
mais l'on parle d'êtres humains et de
famille de gens qui nous ont aidés en
afghanistan le ministre de l'immigration
se défend me n'ira pas plus loin nous
versons faire dans notre engagement
voyons s'il est au moins qui rompit
réseau tissons arcana aussi rapidement
et en toute sécurité
le principal obstacle demeure le manque
d'itinéraires sûre et fiable pour sortir
du pays nous traitons dès demain aux
jurés lui ai ren mobiliser l'ensemble de
notre réseau mondial pour livrer les
wizzards urgences
pendant ce temps des zones et hakim se
rappelle de bons souvenirs de la mission
canadienne en afghanistan et
l'interprète rêve de pouvoir un jour
réunir ses neuf frères et soeurs ici à
cultiver j'espère les revoir bientôt je
n'ai aucune idée si cela sera possible
mais je ne perds pas espoir dit il
en attendant hakim a trouvé une nouvelle
famille
pour moi et pour mes parents il fait
partie de la famille on célèbre l'action
de grâces et noël ensemble je les
adopter ma famille aussi c'est tout
simplement comme ça conclut-il
et si valérie gamache radio canada
ottawa